The Federal Reserve is expected to announce...
…a third consecutive 75 basis point interest hike today.
That's right.
A lot of folks will be saying "ouch",...
…because this action would mark the fifth rate increase this year.
The aggressive move is part of the Fed's strategy to fight inflation,...
…and this would come roughly one week after the Labor Department...
…released the latest consumer price index report.
That CPI report showed prices in this country...
…remained near a four decade high last month.
Joining us now is Mark Hamrick.
He is a senior economic analyst for bankrate.com
Mark, thanks for being here.
Please explain to our viewers...
…who is going to be most affected by this interest rate hike.
Americans. People who are participants in our economy.
That's everyone, Mark.
Exactly. That's what I mean.
Everyone will be affected by this.
This is a far-reaching action on the part of the Federal Reserve.
And it reverberates all around the world, so it has a global impact as well.
The people who have been feeling some of the pain year-to-date...
…are those who have exposure to the stock market.
We know we're in a bear market.
We know that the housing market is slow today.
We had the seventh straight month of decline in existing home sales.
But, make no mistake.
Inflation has taken all consumers hostage.
Businesses as well.
And so, the Fed is prescribing further medicine,...
…and as you said, this is the strongest medicine that it has delivered...
...in the sense of the third straight,...
…presumably, interest rate hike of 75 basis points in the third of five.